la sortie a été plutôt hésitante mais
très vite les ovins ont pris leurs
marques leur présence n'est pas anodine
ils vont entretenir le parc du château
de plaisir faire de l'éco pâturages
c'est un nettoyer les espaces verts
à l'aide des animaux c'est les animaux
pâture
les cités et nettoie tout en préservant
bien sûr c'est ce qui est le plus
essentiel en préservant la biodiversité
des sites et
favorisa
le développement de l'écosystème en fait
présent à la demande de la mairie les
ovins seront dans le parc durant un an
pas d'économies pour la commune
l'entretien des jardins représentent
2800 euros chaque année c'est dans
l'esprit du zéro phyto que la ville
applique déjà depuis trois ans puisque
au niveau de l'ensemble des espaces de
la ville où il ya donc de l'herbe
utilisons donc l'eau chaude on a donc
sélectionné deux parcelles sur le parc
du château une par une parcelle d'un
hectare 6 une parcelle d'un hectare 2 et
donc le berger va vous nous déplacer le
mouton sur ses différentes parcelles
dans deux mois ils seront mis à l'abri
pour l'hiver avant de repartir
entretenir les autres zones du parc est
allé à la rencontre des plaisirs oit